I love when he calls into our show he is
yet to show up in person in Los Angeles
so I heard when he was going to be
working for eighties audience network
this week conducting interviews and
given fans an inside look at some of the
hottest parties throughout the week
including the EA sports madden party the
DirecTV now Super Saturday night party I
thought maybe he'd be here all week
certainly showing up as he always does
on the field after a to pick performance
in the Pro Bowl I thought he'd be here
but he's not coming to later in the week
so there's only two words for Patrick
Peterson to welcome it into the Rich
Eisen show that's that's weaksauce
Patrick that's it it's cold here we need
you here yeah I just got home from the
Pro Bowl
actually watching the rerun of the
Farmers Insurance Open right now oh you
are so no no no Patrick hold on a minute
you're working for the audience Network
later this week you need to be saying
you're watching the Rich Eisen show
after having watched the Dan Patrick
show you where you know I know that
there is an eye in Patrick but you're
part of the team yeah you're right
that's right I am definitely working for
audience for six weeks
hmm it's gonna be a crazy week but I
love love love golf but and I do but I
do want to show I'm always into now I
love show okay - you guys are definite
my favorite by belonging very good so uh
what part you up to and the farmer do
you say you you know what's happened
right I mean I don't want to spoil it
for you yeah yeah yeah I know I know
what happened but I have to see it
laughing myself I was busy yesterday so
okay no I know very very well aware of
that how was that experience I know it
was your seventh crack addict what what
do you think of it it was fun honestly
because it was it was a it was a weird
in a sense because it was the first time
that it actually might rain and pour
down and having like another team rain
jacket on you know that was I was pretty
weird but the game itself that was fun
had a lot of energy in it a lot of real
football move or actions I think the
fans was definitely at home enjoy this
one
if they did but I saw also the usual
like these guys aren't trying and I'm
like you try and rehab something for six
months or eight months or maybe miss an
entire part of your regular season
coming up next year if you hurt yourself
I mean do you guys go into the game
thinking that while you suit up like I
don't want to get hurt that's playing in
that game you know they've been there so
you know we understand and know how to
take care one another because I've been
in today's expedition game it's a fun
game but it's also a competitive game
and we have that competitive edge as you
saw in the fourth quarter as those guys
came back and I don't know how to hit
they pulled out their victory but it did
but we understand how to take care of
one another because at the end of the
day you know we have we have something
big a bigger picture to take care of and
that's obviously for our organization
well what about taking care of you each
other during the playing season
sometimes it seems like a lot of bad
blood and it seems like sometimes shots
are taken by defensive players that are
potentially avoidable what are you
saying on that front
Patrick sometimes you know you see what
happened with Jalen Ramsey AJ Green just
as if for instance I know that's an
extreme example but sometimes those
things I just think just just just
something that happened in a moment and
you know at the end of the day you have
to look at what's going how the game is
unfolding you know what what part of the
game that you know if this guy's if AJ
was getting targets you know so it's a
lot of things that that can go into
situations like that I will never say
it's any bad blood because you can even
an offseason when from from from my
experiences you know I see guys and
officers from rival rival teams you know
it's always love look at that end of the
day you know we're when a fraternity
that that could never be you know taken
away from it so at the end of the day
when we get between their lives
we're playing for something different
but when we step away from the game it's
total difference so
I will just say things like that is just
something to happen say that just
happened in a moment Patrick Peterson
seven-time Pro Bowler from the Arizona
Cardinals joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show and then one of the pics that
you you had yesterday there was a big
smile on your face is it looks like
Delanie Walker is trying to take you
down and I saw this on Twitter because I
do follow you on twitter at p2 the
letter P and then the number two and you
tweeted this photograph out through all
the disrespect and everything I
accomplished on the field going
unnoticed I still smile that will never
change hashtag truth who are you
referring to because I gotta be honest
II I don't I don't know those people
who are you referring to Patrick this I
will just say sometimes you know the
fake pictures never looked at and am I
for me and I just think sometimes you
know if I said Francis a couple years
ago in 2014 when I gave up you know
seven touchdowns or whatever the number
was you know having many catches I gave
up you know that that's front page you
know that's you know why why this guy
doing this you shouldn't be paid they
start another but on the flip side of
that when guys don't show up on the stat
sheet far as receivers and I don't get
any targets that goes unnoticed that
goes on talked about you know and and
all I do and and all I do is work to
work my tail off each and every Sunday
obviously I want I want targets but I
can't I can't force the quarterback to
throw the ball my way you know it's you
know I mean so I just feel just
sometimes you know my play
go on notice but when something big
happen on me happens on me is look you
know look at this look at that I told
you these I mean they just and I don't
care I don't really play pay close
attention to what they say just birth me
just when I played English football and
do what I supposed to and not give up it
catches and not supposed to you know
give up touchdowns it's just sometimes
it goes unnoticed and another thing I
saw on your Twitter feed at Pete
one week ago today in caps I love it
that was right around when it was
announced your new head coach was the
defensive coordinator of the Carolina
Panthers Steve Wilkes what do you love
about it oh I love that
the Judiasm I hear that he brings to the
table you know talking to our I was
fortunate enough to talk to Thomas Davis
senior throughout the Pro Bowl week and
just trying to you know just trying to
get a feel of them and now just hear
nothing but great things about coach
wolf so I'm excited to finally have a
deepest minded coach as a head coach um
and it should be fun it should be fun
switching over to a 4-3 that I hear um
so it should present a lot a lot of more
opportunities for this defense to make
plays in the fashion sure do you think
Larry's coming back do you think Larry
Fitzgerald's got one more in him at
least Patrick what do you think oh my
gut feeling says he thought he's calm
he'll be back because I mean he's plan
to well I told him I don't know that
Larry is familiar with the Father father
of time okay they look like he's getting
better with age you know so my guts
gonna say say he come comes back but you
never know it Oh fitzy a couple more
questions for you here
Patrick Theater Tsin you're a member of
the paparazzi this week so let me ask
you let's let's get you as a member of
the media analyzing Super Bowl 50 to how
do you think this plays out here in
Minneapolis between the Eagles in the
pages I really don't like dictions but
I'm just really looking for a good game
and it's tough to bet against Tom Brady
but Philly is hot right now so honestly
I'm just look I'm just I'm just looking
for a great game and I think it's going
to be a great game because it Philly
jumps up everybody's going to be
watching to see if Tom Brady can pull it
out again if Tom Brady is up everybody's
going to do you know excited to see him
well I want to say a cider book and
treat and see him getting a 60 range so
it's gonna it's going to be a great game
and I'm just looking for great how do
you think Aaron's is going to be in
the media he gets a TV job that we're
all expecting what do you think oh he's
gonna be great for TV no coach coach is
gonna be great for TV I can't wait to
see him you know that that smile that he
had that that personality that he had
he's definitely gonna have a lot of
people too okay but and then Patrick
last one for you this could be the most
important question I've asked you
throughout this interview okay do you
have a 9-volt battery in the house for
that fire alarm that keeps chirping
Patrick yes yes I have any give me any
tips for gonna be dope absolutely here
you go Patrick be yourself be yourself
make sure that you ask as many questions
that aren't yes or no answers you don't
want to give you you never want to give
yourself your subject the opportunity to
just say yes or no never give up the
microphone okay that some people might
try to pull it away from you and if you
are anywhere in my vicinity if we're
doing something together and you're in
any trouble at all the safe words are
back to you rich I've got your back
okay and also make sure for your
microphone that you have a spare battery
in case the batteries go dead now tell
me please tell me you don't have these
high ceilings in your house that you
that you're gonna have this like
eight-foot ladder that you might there
it is again
I don't have it's not a high high
ceiling to get my little ladder okay in
my living room and go change this out be
careful okay
all right Patrick you take care of that
we'll see out here shortly okay Patrick
Peterson
oh man the number of tweets we got
change your smoke detector
as Patrick to take care of that 9-volt
battery Oh fantastic the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience